uh one how are you doing and um
how are the guys doing and uh you know
it's been a rough i imagine a very
emotional couple days and uh
you know how do you feel about getting
back to
you know to play and be ready to go
tomorrow i'm actually pretty drained
um i mean it's definitely been a very
emotional past couple of days not only
for
myself but everyone um
it's kind of ironic to be here on the
anniversary of the
march on washington and the unfortunate
death of emmett till and cedar would
still fight these
same social injustices on a daily basis
and
first and foremost i got to give a lot
of credit to our players
our players it's it's been a hard time
um everyone uh showed in a lot
but uh the communication that we're
having uh has been amazing
um i think what everyone saw in the past
couple days was
you know guys just needing to to
to reset refocus and that's what we did
next up we have tanya ganguly with the
la times
um there were obviously a lot of
emotions were pretty high obviously on
wednesday night
i'm wondering how how
uh how concerned were you that the
lakers would actually
that lebron and the lakers would
actually decide that they didn't want to
continue
it was never about one person it was
never about one
team it was all about all of us together
when the events happened or the other
day of the game
we we stood in solidarity with our
brothers from milwaukee
you know everything that we do is about
um
the the brotherhood about everyone as a
whole
so it was never about what is this one
team what is one player is going to do
what we did in there is we had deep
conversations and we all really had an
opportunity to address a lot of things
you know the shootings that continue to
happen it creates a lot of unrest
a whole lot of unrest for us to have a
predominantly african-american league
to see um you know our black brothers
being shot and killed
on a daily basis you know it's it just
doesn't make a lot of sense to us and so
everyone expects us to go out and play i
get it but
we needed some time all of us we needed
some time to
to refocus and and understand um
you know that we can do that we're human
at the end of the day
a lot of times people pass a lot of
judgment about what we should do or what
we shouldn't do
but guys i give our guys a lot of credit
because they've been doing a hell of a
job
a hell of a job down here performing and
speaking on the different social
injustice that's going on day in and day
out
while trying to be a great athlete while
trying to be
a great husband while trying to be a
great father so
yeah next up we got mark spears with the
undefeated
uh chris why what what made the union
comfortable going back to work
and also what are the things in
particular that
you're excited about um i think we
talked
we talked as players our first meet we
actually had coaches and everyone in
there
and it was great to get a lot of insight
from i tell you armand hill
doc rivers gave some some great insight
john lucas but at the end of the day our
players spoke
and we spoke and we we understood the
the platform that we have
that we have and we wanted to keep our
our foot to the pedal right and keep
speaking on the different things that
are occurring
and we also decided that we wanted to
start a justice coalition
right so that we could um
on a daily basis make sure that there
are checks and balances and also
continue to attack
uh police brutality and all these
different things one of the biggest
things that guys talked about in our
meeting which was great that we got a
chance to get together and discuss these
things is voting
voting is something that uh everyone in
the room was very passionate about
we got a chance to discuss we got a
chance to talk to the different
governors and tell them how
you know we want uh all of the nba
arenas to be polling sites
right and uh it's funny i had a
conversation with j.r smith on my way
over here and j.r told me that
he had spoke to the mayor where he's
from and they're going to open up
an arena there for for voting you know
so this is huge in these different
cities that
may not be able to do their arena maybe
it's their practice facility yeah
right and uh another thing that god
spoke about is
while we're out there playing you know
we're the product we're the game
during these commercials we would like
to see um
advertisement for voting right we
understand
how strong our voice is how powerful our
voice is and
you know ultimately we decided uh if we
go away from this stage we
we don't necessarily have that same
platform so we stood in solidarity
you know we're going to continue to to
play but we're also going to continue to
make sure that our voices are heard
seems like you guys are shifting more
now to concentrating on voting
you know the other thing too is not just
make sure our voices are heard we're
about action
we're about action and that's what our
meeting was about it was about the real
action you know god said you know we've
been saying this we've been saying that
but what's the action
and so uh in our meetings we had a big
meeting with all the players and
then we had a smaller meeting where two
players from every team came
and i think that was very informational
and we got a chance to talk to the
different governors and we told them the
action that we wanted to see in place
chris paul speaking on the joint
statement between the nba and players
association mentioning the poetry of it
happening on the 57th anniversary of the
march on washington
and the 65th anniversary of the brutal
murder of emmett teal
taking a look at the joint statement
number one establish a social justice
coalition that will focus on the issues
including voting
civil engagement and advocating for
meaningful police and criminal justice
reform
number two in every nba city create a
safe in-person voting option for
communities
vulnerable to covet 19 and the third
work with players and network partners
to create and
include advertising spots in each
playoff game promoting greater
civic engagement in elections in raising
awareness
around voting access let's go back to
chris
what we're paul right now in our league
is huge and i think for the young guys
in our league to get a chance to see how
guys are really coming together and
speak
and and see real change real action
because guys are tired
like i mean tired and i'm saying when i
say tired we're not physically tired
we're just tired of seeing the same
thing over and over again
right i was blessed and fortunate enough
to to talk to jacob
um to talk to jacob blake's father
and um he's a winston-salem state
graduate and was in my hometown of
winston-salem for a while and it's
emotional
it's emotional especially when you're a
black man and you know that
uh when george hill sport he talked
about being a black man he was hurt
he was hurt we all hurt we we all tired
of just seeing the same thing
over and over again and everybody just
expect us to be okay just because we get
paid great money
you know we're human we have really real
feelings and i'm glad that we got a
chance to get in the room together
to talk with one another and not just
cross paths and say
good luck in your game today so people
who
are hearing this message and seeing what
has happened the last couple days
what is the most important thing that
you want them to understand
um just understand that you you got a
league here
that understands um
that is not just about any one of us um
you know our wnba ladies still with us
uh all the other leagues whether it be
baseball whether it be hockey
whatever whatever it is that you know
we're human just like anybody else we
don't always do everything
right but i tell you for me it's been
really tough
it's been really tough just for the
simple fact that when things like this
happen i like to talk to my kids about
it
you know i'm a long way from my kids i
can't explain to them
why this video was going all over the
internet i have 11 year old black
son black son who was witne
witnessing this stuff day in and day out
and
the president of players association
chris paul speaking to the media brendan
what were your takeaways from chris
paul's statements
um my biggest thing was like at the end
when he really started talking about
like not being around his son
and not being able to explain some of
the things that are going on
that that's the real life element of
what's going on we know that chris paul
being the president he's trying to get
things done behind the scenes he's
definitely trying to affect real change
and that's that's the
that that's the best thing that's coming
out of this is that uh
the nba players chris paul adams over
there all working together to affect
real change in the community this is no
longer about symbolic gestures this
isn't about
just the black lives matters t-shirts
this is about how can we really put
boots on the ground and find a way to
impact the community so i think that
the fact that chris paul is is a huge
part of that is great
and then also like just hearing him
talking about his son and not being able
to explain some of these things that are
going around with that video
where mr blake was shot and in the back
several times in front of his own kids
and
what that means and how that affects his
children that's it's
just heartbreaking smitty what did you
take away from the players association
as president
you know first of all um like dwight
brendan said i i
thought all of it was fantastic but what
sometimes everything stands out to
different people
for me just the human element side um
echo and everything brennan said
is this fan is this unbearable what
these players have to go through
and also still perform but then the
human side of this
he just said which is nothing wrong
weakness needed to reset
you know and you start thinking about
all the pressure like we've been talking
about
you know to be able to reset obviously
he had to do a lot of
things with every stressful situation
but to need a reset
they're human and that's the one thing
he's looking at and what they're talking
about is
real humans you know black men are
getting shot
right in front of us that is hard for
all of us to watch and see
and have no answers you know come from
it and for like the brianna taylor
situation
no one arrested from it that's just hard
to see like we just supposed to
keep going as not nba players as people
human being
just keep going along with our day when
there's no justice
i agree with you 100 refocused
reorganization that seems to be taking
place with the players association in
the nba
releasing a joint statement with
initiatives that are going to take place
soon